This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6 Minute English.
From BBC Learning English.
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English.
I'm Sam.
And I'm Neil. How are you today, Sam?
Thanks for asking, Neil. I'm fine.
Not.
Sorry, so are you fine or not?
Oh, did I confuse you? My bad.
Ah, Sam is speaking English, just a very modern type of English.
For example, saying, my bad instead of my fault,
as a way of accepting that she's wrong.
Or adding not at the end of a sentence to show,
I really mean the opposite of what I said.
Both are examples of small changes in English,
which have happened naturally over the last decade or two.
Changes like these happen, because unlike, say, Latin,
which no one speaks day to day,
English is a living language.
A language people speak and use in their ordinary lives.
New bits of English are invented as people use the language in new ways.
But what happens when a language comes from an entirely different galaxy?
Somewhere like Cronos, home planet of the Klingon.
Yes, when sci-fi TV show Star Trek
introduced alien characters called Klingons,
the makers needed to invent a whole new language, Klingon.
Entirely made up and unrelated to any human language,
Klingon has developed a life of its own.
Today, you can even study it at university.
So, Neil, my quiz question is this.
In 2010, Klingon became the first invented language to do what?
Is it A, have its own dictionary?
B, have an opera written, or C, be recognised as an official language
by the United Nations?
Every language needs vocabulary, so I'll say A, Klingon,
was the first invented language to have its own dictionary.
Okay, Neil, I'll reveal the answer later in the programme.
Klingon isn't the only made up language invented for the movies.
David Peterson is the creator of Dothraki,
a language used in the fantasy TV show Game of Thrones.
From his home in Los Angeles,
David spoke to Michael Rosen, presenter of BBC Radio 4 programme Word of Mouth.
They discussed St. Hildegard,
who created the very first made up language in the 12th century.
What she had was an entire list of nouns, a whole list of nouns.
Many of them godly, many of them not.
And she would drop them into songs using Latin grammar,
and other Latin words.
And so, it's not a language proper as the way that we understand it now.
Because really, when we talk about a language,
it's not just the vocabulary, it's the grammar.
Nevertheless, we still kind of look on her
as the patron saint of modern Klingon.
St. Hildegard invented new nouns, but used Latin grammar.
So David doesn't think her invention is a proper language.
Nevertheless, St. Hildegard is considered the patron saint of made up languages.
The patron saint of something refers to a Christian saint
who is believed to give special help to a particular activity.
Here, the activity is inventing a conlang,
short for constructed language,
artificially invented languages like Klingon and Dothraki.
Another famous, constructed language, Esperanto,
was invented in 1887 by Polish doctor Ludwig Zamenhof.
He wanted to make it easier for people who spoke different languages
to communicate with each other.
Listen, as David Peterson speaks Esperanto with Michael Rosen
and tests how much he understands for BBC Radio 4 program, Word of Mouth.
You are an English speaker from Western Europe.
And in the 19th century, Universal meant able to be understood
by people from Western Europe.
And so, for example, to say I speak Esperanto,
mi parolaise, Esperanto.
Yes, I might have got that one.
The pal bit from its Latin root and me, obviously.
Try me again.
Kiel vi fertas.
Who is my father? No.
Where am I traveling?
No, I got stuck on that one.
Like Spanish, Italian and other modern European languages,
Esperanto is based on Latin.
Michael guessed the meaning of the Esperanto word,
parolellas, from its Latin root,
the origin or source of a language.
But the second sentence of Esperanto isn't so easy.
Michael gets stuck on that one.
He can't answer because it's too difficult.
I think I'd probably get stuck on that as well.
But at least, Esperanto was invented for humans,
not alien creatures from outer space.
And speaking of creatures from outer space,
did I get the right answer to your quiz question, Sam?
Ah, so I asked Neil about an unusual first
achieved by the made up alien language, Klingon.
I guess it was the first invented language
to have its own dictionary.
Which was the wrong answer I'm afraid, Neil.
Incredibly, the correct answer was B.
In 2010, a company of Dutch musicians and singers
performed the first ever Klingon Opera.
The story must have been hard to follow,
but I'm sure the singing was out of this world.
Magica, that's Klingon for great, apparently.
OK, let's recap the vocabulary from our discussion
about invented languages, also called
constructed languages or conlangs for short.
A living language, like English,
is a language that people still speak
and use in their ordinary lives.
The phrase, my bad, originated in the United States,
but is also used in Britain as an informal way
to say, my fault.
Or to tell someone that you've made a mistake.
A patron saint is someone believed to give special help
and protection to a particular activity.
The root of a language means its origin or source.
And finally, if you get stuck on something,
you're unable to complete it because it's too difficult.
That's all the time we have for this programme
about invented languages.
Gis-Ravido Baldao, that's Esperanto for See You Again Soon.
In other words, Kepler, which is how Klingon say goodbye, I think.
Kepler. Kepler.